you just tape the Alec Baldwin roast
yeah and you I heard you were hilarious
you had great jokes yeah Blake Griffin
was you know MBA so sniffing and you you
like Blake Griffin he's a very
good-looking very talented man I don't
know anything about sports
I really don't but he's so hot and he I
know that he played for the Clippers and
now he plays for the Pistons and yeah
which I like I don't know about sports I
I just know that that's not good and
[Laughter]
maybe I had a chance and I got seated
next to him during the roast cuz I asked
for it and so that was advantageous and
I'm and so I go up there and all of my
jokes about him if you watch it or just
about how much I want to have sex with
him and it was all fun and he laughed
and hahaha and I sit back down then he
gets up to do his set and it's all about
how he would never have sex with me Oh
like ever oh my god and then we had to
sit next to each other for the next
three hours and act like everything was
okay and it was it was it was have been
I mean he's kidding they're jokes but
yeah are they and it was so tough
because afterwards I was kind of bummed
I was like no no that didn't feel great
and then my friend who was a writer for
the roast was like I really like that
one joke he did where he says that you
look like the hairdresser of someone he
might have sex with and I go he didn't
say that and she goes oh sorry and I'm
like that one didn't make it yeah it was
a Robert De Niro was they what Robert De
Niro was there I know he's my favorite
Al Pacino character I just love it's
pretty put that like I I did say that I
learned a lot about him
I believed I normally know him from his
most recent films which like they're
they're the type of movies that Netflix
asks are you still watching you know
after the credits and or after the
opening credits but uh so I I did find
out about him that his father is was gay
and an artist I didn't know that yeah
yeah and so he decided to honor his
father late in his career by only
accepting roles that suck
isn't that cool oh my god okay these
work better if I read that you keep
these in your boot yeah does I always
keep some tried-and-true
Caitlyn Jenner I went off to her her
pretty hard for just being like a bad
mother
there's so much to go after her for and
I just wanted to tap into the fact that
she like you know she kind of abandoned
one family to go to the other one and I
said you know Stevie Wonder sees his
kids more than you do
good lord I know good lord I know and so
it didn't work out with Blake Griffin
huh yeah well people kept reminding
Blake that I was not a trap like well
Blake said that I looked like Larry Bird
[Laughter]
doesn't feel good
it was fun I love that you got them in
your boot I didn't want to forget any of
those yeah you did you got a boy I think
I got